hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got our first look at the new team arrow
I also wanted to address Black Canary
coming back we will see black carry
throughout the season and Deathstroke
many thanks to Stephen Amell for
clearing up all the destro confusion so
here we go so far and away most
surprising thing that made me really
happy from the comics is mr. terrific
wearing the face makeup because that's
something that you could have totally
changed like wild dog Artemis all you
know relatively true in the real-world
sense to their comic book personas
Artemis wears a version of the costume
that looks pretty similar to Oliver's
she just doesn't have the hood part so
it just makes me really happy that they
are going super comic book II with
season 5 which I think everybody wants
like everyone wants it to be as close to
the comics as possible with within like
the stuff that they've already done like
I'm not expecting Green Lantern to show
up like it would be amazing like the
most ridiculous comic book thing they
could possibly do would be to give
Oliver a Green Lantern ring not gonna do
that on arrow anytime soon but that's
totally ok the show's called
arrow it was born after Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy came out so
visually you expect it to flow from that
you know with like a little bit of
powers whenever flash stuff crosses over
but I think this picture was taken in
the last week or so meaning that this is
from around episode 5 so you get the
idea we're slowly building towards the
big midseason crossover which is gonna
be episode 8 I think Kevin Smith just
went up to the flash set to start
episode 6 that's gonna be his episode of
the flash so I'm guessing arrows about
the same place in terms of progress
arrow and the flash started shooting
both seasons about the same time they
don't always move at the same pace like
sometimes the flash will be a little bit
ahead of arrow sometimes arrow will be a
little head of the flash but I think
everybody's gonna be pretty happy with
the changes they made so far but the
cool thing is is like when you zoom in a
little bit on this picture like if you
didn't notice right away there are two
more people standing behind Oliver and
Artemis there so one that looks like
Diggle behind Oliver you kind of see
like a version of diggle's helmet we
haven't seen how they've changed it like
they said they changed it a little bit
this season so maybe it looks a little
bit more like the guardians helmet from
the comics and that might be a rag man
behind Artemis it's kind of hard to tell
just because all you see is like a
really dark cloak Ragman another big
comic book character they're doing this
season but we haven't seen a whole
of them in the trailers like there's a
picture of them right here but the
Prometheus character who's like the big
bad character is wearing a costume that
looks very much like Oliver's it's kind
of like a patchwork looking thing so
it's easy to confuse him with Ragman
just because of like the patchwork
nature of their costumes but
Prometheus's costume is intended to be
like a dark twist on Oliver season one
costume well really he wore that costume
for the first two seasons like the cloth
costume so let me know what you guys
think about their costumes so far I know
everybody wants to see mr. terrific with
the tea spheres just unloading on super
villains because he's an Olympic bronze
medalist but it looks like we're gonna
see the evolution of him in the first
couple of episodes through like this
oliver training montage there's like
this very 80s vibe that i totally love
the arrows giving off right now we have
the russia flashbacks with Dolph
Lundgren so we have rocky 4 training
montage train for the big title fight
you could also make a number of he-man
references Stephen Amell posted this
he-man gift the other day just totally
perfect very appropriate I'm gonna have
to load up on these before we see Dolph
Lundgren in the flashbacks but if you
are wondering about the other like
former team arrow people if the people
that bailed at the end of last season
like Diggle went back to the military I
don't think they'll be gone for forever
like they're all still main cast members
so we'll still see everybody in the
first couple of episodes but obviously
Oliver puts this new team together with
these different people so what I'm
guessing is is that throughout the
course of the season you'll just see
people come and go on Team arrow like
largely you have the new team arrow
maybe like one or two people will come
and go but Diggle will still be around
even if he's not around the whole time
and like Thea isn't wearing her costume
anymore she's not going out with Oliver
I don't think that that's gonna stick
either usually it's like a very
Godfather thing where it's like you try
to leave a life behind like a life of
violence but if dark forces won't let
you leave it behind so I think like Thea
is supposed to be working with Oliver
inside the mayor's office that's where
most of her early scenes are gonna be I
feel like she's still gonna have some
action scenes they just might not be
with her wearing the red costume so you
guys can let me know in the comments but
I feel like everyone's biggest question
now like we have an idea for what arrow
is gonna look like the biggest question
is is how is Black Canary going to come
back because Katie Cassidy will always
continue to guest star on the show
she'll pop up from time to time but the
only
Confirmation we really have is that
you'll show up in flashbacks like that's
the easiest way to bring her back
because season one Laurel will always be
alive and at the end of last season
after they killed her off they're like
this version of Laurel will never come
back no Lazarus Pit no timey wimey
explanation so everyone's like okay so
who's gonna be coming back as black
siren gonna be coming on the show is it
gonna be like an alternate universe
version of Black Canary because they'll
always be a form of Black Canary
somewhere in like the arrowverse but not
necessarily always on arrow like we'll
have Supergirl crossovers we'll have the
flash crossovers definitely with black
siren and then you have legends of
tomorrow
so if we see Laurel as Black Canary on
arrow in present day I think the two
most likely ways that that happens is if
Sara on legends of tomorrow
Yanks one out of time like Yanks a
laurel out of time so that she's alive
in that sense or we get full-on black
siren from the flash so I think really
like the only thing we could absolutely
count on is that there'll be some crazy
comic-book explanation so like if you've
read comic books in the past if you've
reven read like one comic book in the
past you were prepared for like a big
twist with Laurel coming back but I
think everybody just really wants to get
to the point where we see it happen
we're like oh okay that's how they did
it and I will go on the record as saying
I'm gonna be super pissed if we get to
like the end of arrows run if they get
to like seven seasons and Oliver never
has to go up against black siren what
I'm really hoping is I made a joke about
this a while ago is that I'm hoping that
earth to Oliver Queen did not die on the
island it's like a big Sara twist from
season two where it's like oh my god
Sara you didn't die you didn't go down
with the boat and he comes back is like
a Deathstroke version of Oliver so it's
like darkest timeline Oliver that maybe
has like one I like slate like maybe
Oliver lost and I on earth too so I know
a lot of you are asking about
Deathstroke - I think I addressed this
in the last like big movie Deathstroke
video that I did but Stephen Amell did
come out and say just because they're
doing them in the movies doesn't mean
that they can't do them on the TV show
it's just that Manu Bennett is a series
regular on another TV show so it's a
question of timing and finding the right
story but yes our version of Deathstroke
from Earth one will
only come back in the future so let me
know in the comments how do you think
that Black Canary is going to come back
on arrow in what version of Black Canary
do you think she's gonna be and when do
you think that we're gonna see
Deathstroke again but because we're
getting really close to episode 1
dropping I'm expecting a few more
trailers like a little bit more footage
in the next week or two still waiting on
that Supergirl Superman trailer they
really are getting down to the wire on
that but there's probably a bunch of
special effects and they probably want
to put metallo in that trailer too but I
will say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Myles Martin you win a
copy of the flash season 2 on blu-ray
you could have the arrow blu-ray if you
want to it's really like either one of
the blu-rays so please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact info I'll keep
doing the blu-ray giveaway until the
series premiere that first week in
October
so nowhere plenty of opportunities to
win free stuff so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so next video will
probably be Game of Thrones they just
confirmed that there's gonna be a big
team-up that we thought might be coming
in season 7 so I'll post a video for
that on Sunday so while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my last big flash trailer and you can
click here for big infinity war behind
the scenes teaser with Thanos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight